this is one of the great national
tragedies of my lifetime
this is one of america's darkest days um
i have been
absolutely despondent watching this i'm
here in d.c i'm sad
is the overwhelming emotion that i feel
what was so hard i think for so many of
us who have grieving hearts is
these images are not our america
this is not the america that you know
megan mccain chelsea clinton
and jenna bush hager weigh in after
violent riots break out at the u.s
capitol you are hurting our country you
are becoming a national embarrassment
and we have to get him out immediately
because this cannot stand
during thursday's episode of the view
megan called for the 25th amendment to
be invoked
which would allow the vice president
with the support of the majority of the
president's cabinet
to declare the president unfit for
office
a move that could lead to the
president's early removal
and would make the vice president the
acting president
the bedrock of our democracy and the
bedrock of who we are as americans is
the peaceful transition of power
and he is clearly a president who has
turned into a mad king
and at this point i'm calling on all
republicans and conservatives who still
have clout
we have to invoke the 25th amendment we
cannot withstand this
our country cannot go on like this and
we cannot possibly
risk the idea that we could have more
violence between now
and president biden getting elected and
inaugurated
the daughter of the late senator john
mccain went on to call the rioters
bastards
and slammed them for using the american
flag as symbols as they are attacking
our own republic
you are not patriots you do not
represent america you are scum
of the earth who are using and abusing
and bastardizing all that i love and
have grown up with
for your own sick agenda and while megan
was getting mad
chelsea clinton admitted on the drew
barrymore show that watching the whole
thing
just made her sad i am
just uh so achingly sad
that we had insurrectionists um
storm or capital it's just
horrifying to me and then trying to
explain what
was happening to our children um
i'm very sad i'm very sad today the
former first daughter revealed that she
was actually the one to break the news
that thousands of president trump's
extremists had stormed congress
amid the electoral college vote count to
her famous parents
hillary and bill clinton i spoke to my
mom yesterday
uh at about three um
and she had uh
just come back on her walk she hadn't
seen what had happened drew so i said
mom i said
you have to you have to turn on the
television um
and there was just silence
like there was just silence
and and then so much sadness and also
um so much anger that this was happening
as for jenna bush hager she got
emotional talking to her co-host hoda
kotb
on the today show thursday what was so
hard i think
for so many of us who have grieving
hearts is these images
are not our america this is not the
america that you know
this is not the america that i know it's
not the america that we want our kids to
know
so that was hard the 39 year old
daughter of former president george w
bush and first lady laura bush added
that her first-hand experience with the
historic building where presidential
inaugurations are held
made the images of the riot all the more
upsetting
i have had the privilege of standing on
those steps
and and several inaugurations not just
for family members
but for the first black president of the
united states of america
when i was a teacher in inner city dc
and that meant
so much to so many i kissed my
grandfather goodbye
and that rotunda i have felt the majesty
of our country in those walls and nobody
can take that from any of us
and the mom of three went on to share a
message of hope with viewers following
the disturbing events
the casual cruelty that we find in the
internet
in in the words of leaders that do not
reflect
our country can we we can stop that
we can share kindness and smiles and
love
and we can and we can take back what is
our country that we all love so
very very much and i you know i just
i have optimism i've seen you um seeing
people i love i mean i have to say i
want to hug
so many people today that's a hardship
but seeing people that represent the
good
um spotlighting them like we have an
opportunity
and i and i think i have faith that our
country will be better